hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control ra.l
2-3.11.3 remediate vulnerabilities in
accordance with risk assessments
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it I mean okay this control is honestly
pretty obvious a rare find in the nist
control world but basically as it states
if it's broken duh fix it let's look at
the assessment points here and see
exactly what we need to do to make those
assessors happy so two things we need to
do one determine if vulnerabilities are
identified lots and lots of ways to do
that again you can see examples from it
ticketing system uh you know things like
your endpoint management solution your
antivirus your firewall all of those
things are going to basically be places
where you can determine if
vulnerabilities are identified and of
course you're going to talk about them
in your quarterly risk management
meeting notes and email alert examples
lots of places to demonstrate this
second assessment point is determine if
vulnerability abilities are remediated
in accordance with risk assessments
again this is implemented C poem and
risk management meeting sop additional
evidence may be found in the incident
response policy so three different
places that again we're all addressing
those vulnerabilities and how we're
remediating them so uh at on-call we
work with defense contractors just like
you who have had this dfars nist itar
and cmmc compliance stuff dropped into
their laps like a seal on a sunny day
baby and we teach you how to level up
and be a proper on-call compliance hero
for your company eliminating gaps great
areas and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
is your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
now that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you visit cmmc compliance
secrets.com or check out the bio below
for links to get help right now love the
content we're putting out here for you
help us out with a big thumbs up on that
like button or even better smash the
Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance in order to roll it out I'll
tell next compliance tip my friends stay
safe and secure out there hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
[Music]